i'm not trying to take away from them
i'm just trying to speak to you
basically taken away no i'm not trying
to take it away from some arms bro and
then do the same thing that's what
you're saying that should be life
without limbs right
but i'm telling you
i'm telling you
yeah dude you dressed like every [ __ ]
stepson from san diego right now yeah i
saw and i saw a bunch of them the other
day yeah yeah look at the way you guys
don't i was in san diego you like you do
jujitsu red robin
dude
yeah i'll beat the [ __ ] out of your son
oh you think i think it'd be a really
good fight
for example which son they're both tough
but tiger at five he's a minus 150 right
now against you i say you beat him back
second round i'll beat him maybe oh you
say you think your wind is better okay
yeah maybe kids go all out really in the
beginning i don't know kids have cardio
for a day calvin is still running no
field's got to knock him out in the
first round because he ain't going to
but i don't i don't want any use out of
testing though
tiger's juiced up dog is he yep ain't
talking about apple juice dude i'll
frickin
beat that dude's genetics better hmm you
think genetics are pretty good yeah we
don't need anything
but depends i mean his genetics are
pretty good i mean they might not last a
long time
hey i want to post this me so bad it
shows forrest gump you know when he they
tell me as a son he goes
is is he like me or is he smart
who poses me is forced right when he
finds out he has a kid it says it says
dads at every parent teacher conference
meeting oh yeah does he like me or is he
smart yeah you made that up
no so my brother
yeah i'll post that [ __ ] um
there he is
white belt what is he a wife out there
he no he's a great bit belt now i don't
know what's on there you just got this
gray belt graveyard you only get ice
cream if you guys can take this like i
didn't know there's
kids it goes white gray yellow green
they want to feel like they're achieving
stuff
yeah adults goes white blue and purple
okay i'm leaving i'm making progress you
know i want that for me now still
what those achievements i just like
achievements bro yeah i want you to hose
to roll he did some jujitsu you think
you're this nashville badass even some
girl beating your ass every tuesday
night oh yeah you've been doing jujitsu
right i saw a picture of something yeah
i'm not a badass dude i am a one stripe
white belt and i go to sometimes lunch
and sometimes evening courses brenden
and how often do you do it
i would say five times a week oh well
that's a little serious oh i'm sorry
what are you gonna compete for how long
why are you doing so much probably four
weeks that's good i mean
you know but sometimes it's in l.a
sometimes it's in nashville sometimes
it's out here well depending on what are
you feeling yourself though are you
feeling yourself like when you're out do
you feel like you're ready yeah you're
ready to get touched
put something in that tough scarf as you
call it no my that hard scarf scarf
daddy i [ __ ] choked some little
piglet the other day out hell yeah um
no i just feel i think my ribs are
starting to feel like separated and [ __ ]
it gets pretty it's hard yeah yeah
especially as you get older it's hard
when people are on top of you people
beating you down the damn dog always
hurt wow you look pretty good there
on the far right you do on the left
you're like a little suspect oh that's
training with dustin poirier's guy out
there daru strong wow and now he's going
to be in prison i think i don't know if
he was or not what happened to that
chain daddy that's dope that's a cool
chain i couldn't find mine i couldn't
find this one i wanted to wear it but
really that's just the game i guess i
[ __ ] couldn't find it that's the game
i know i'm just changing what's the game
the same game your son is just
it just went somewhere i don't know we
don't need a new [ __ ] cleaning lady
to come yeah they can't trust him uh oh
i have to sit there with her here we go
don't get theo involved in this okay i
mean feels like she's latin
no i'll tell you right now we have our
ones that we trust for [ __ ] 15 years
been coming over yeah put a price on
trust right yeah that's what we pay them
extra for they ask for a raise i go like
this my hands are tied of course yes
what am i going to do get new people so
i give them a raise right
well we had a bit of a uh we had a
really uh the super bowl right so after
the super bowl uh there was a bunch of
food left out and [ __ ] kristen had to
study for her therapy stuff she's in
school to become a therapist
as hell bro yeah
we're trying we're trying to get the
extra food yeah we had extra food around
right okay okay
extra food now but chris is
by the way dude we all made it you're
the only one that could maybe ex [ __ ]
remember when i said you're poor in your
heart yeah yeah
that's never going to leave you he's
like a fat girl that lost a lot of
weight
she's still fat he's like shallow
for him i heard you i got a 200 square
foot aorta bro that's one bedroom bro
he gets a studio he just don't want his
cowboy girl moving up so like he can
still stay with those you know what i
mean oh there's no those
gristle bears
undercover rich like no i am not brendan
go bro you go you you could go buy a
ferrari right now and it wouldn't matter
not your life wouldn't change at all you
just have a ferrari that's rich nope you
know what happened they would buy a
ferrari and then complain about gas
that's the only thing there you go in
his heart he's like man it's six dollars
a gallon
so we got a new cleaning ladder that
came and kristen had to leave to go to
the library to study and i'm like oh
[ __ ] damn you're all rich as well so now
i got to stay libraries she wanted to do
it to get out so she would [ __ ] be
focused right okay you know what i mean
in the house with the cleaning lady
there one cleaning lady came by uh well
two came by and oh and one no no listen
to me one of them one of them do your
jokes but it's not the truth go ahead
but it's not the truth
oh [ __ ] two cleaning ladies he's like so
16 ladies come by right man
all right good so a team of cleaning
ladies came over we're going
to come by man go ahead to sanitize the
house yeah the cleaning squad when you
want the truth let me know
so i told security take it easy tonight
yeah
y'all changed bro she changed
i've been this way
[Laughter]
so hold on so so okay so chrissy rich
over here two of them come and one of
them says i'm just dropping my auntie
off i'm leaving right oh i just say oh
okay that's odd and then auntie comes in
and she's like are you gonna put your
dogs up immediately the first thing she
said and i'm like yeah i'll put him up
and she's like okay where and i'm like
well i'll just i don't know i'll put him
upstairs it'll be fine she's like okay
and so she cleans it and she's like do
you have uh
trash bags do you have all this [ __ ] and
i'm like yeah yeah here you go and so
now i go upstairs and i wait right i
just wait because i don't know if she's
gonna need something it's uncomfortable
in my house alone with a stranger and
then i just hear um
and so i'm like okay i guess you want i
go does it yes hi what do you want me to
do with this game she said i don't know
you just put it together and put it in
the game drawer okay i go back up um
i come back down do you mind if i just
do the dishes but do them by hand and
the thing i say whatever you want to do
um so keep with the arms not sir excuse
me whatever which is fine so then she
says the last um
i come downstairs and she's like uh i
can't use my phone i don't know what's
going on and i'm like oh well okay
do you need the wi-fi code and she's
like no it should work anywhere so i
said okay you want to use mine she's
like yeah can you just call the lady to
pick me up can you call my uh to come
pick me up i don't know what i'm doing i
don't know where i am that's what she
said yeah and i'm like all right well
let's call her and we'll figure it out i
call her no answer i text her no answer
okay 20 minutes goes by and she's like i
really don't know what to do here you
think you could drop me off at fairfax
and i go um no
right because no right because i'm not
going to be in the car alone with a
stranger she might jerk the wheel or
something i don't know olympio
trafficking a lot of times they do
olympio trafficking dude where they're a
lot of uh cleaning ladies are really
getting traffic just to yeah cartel i
understand i understand and i want no
part of that you know what i mean
did you find it off craigslist no i
don't so oh so okay so i'll get to it so
so i say all right well i don't know
what to do and then kristen's like
what's going on so the lady says well
she knows she shouldn't have dropped me
off and she should have came back and
now i can't get a hold of her because
she knows i have a nervous condition
that's what she said dude in my house
alone with me there so now i'm like uh
oh
don't tell me you have a condition so
then later on she was like shaking she
starts crying and she says she know i
can't walk to olympic i have a heart
condition and i'm like you have two
conditions
so now i'm like texted kristin and i'm
so pissed like i'm like i'm like good
hired yeah yeah she was like was she in
charge of that
i didn't even know she did it until she
woke up she said by the way these ladies
are coming one lady with two conditions
for the both of them so i'm like all
right
yes
[ __ ] discount i'm trying to pay her
more to leave yeah so she's like so
kristen's like it's reputable it had
five stars i'm like okay fine and she
was like i'm never doing this again i'm
never doing this i'm trying to help her
out and i'm never doing this again so i
get her an uber she's like what car is
it i give i was like blue car and i
[ __ ] she gets in the car she leaves
and then i'm sexy chris where the [ __ ]
are you where are you and she says i'm
up the street i didn't want to come in
because i was scared
[Laughter]
tight move i mean look i'm the [ __ ]
one yeah i'm the famous guy that she's
going to tweet about yeah so help me so
now you gotta find another you know the
team so no so i have so you're lucky she
even spoke english dude fearing cleaning
mine doesn't speak english
i'm stuck in
how long have you known yours
four years there you go
i've known mine for physical there's no
english you're cleaning person and what
happened to them they're great no they
still work they still work but like they
come fridays and she just wanted them to
come now and mine are scheduled up and
we didn't even ask him she was just this
was a bonus she was probably tipsy and
like i'm gonna get it clean tomorrow and
then yeah i get scared sometimes and
i'll get um i'll clean up before
somebody comes to even clean yeah that's
crazy i know a lot of people do that my
girl will do that i don't do that no way
no way
if i know they're coming i'll wipe my
fingers in my towel like if i'm eating
cheetos i'll just wipe my hands in the
bed and make sure they're cleaned yeah
yeah yeah yeah you'll be good to go
because i can clean traps yeah because
clean traps because if there's nothing
that's good that's good i missed it [ __ ]
i hate when i miss it but like episode
name because sometimes
because sometimes i feel like they won't
clean something unless it's really dirty
so [ __ ] yeah i do that [ __ ] eating
cheetos just gotta make sure they get
expectations of like what you want them
to clean that's the annoying part they i
had to make sure like hotel too you
gotta tell them no but you gotta say i
don't
know
like i need the bathroom like this part
of the bathroom too because i hate when
you have somebody clean your place yeah
and then you go and look like yeah why
is that [ __ ] still dirty oh bro the way
i treat hotels
i roll in the [ __ ] sheets yeah [ __ ]
stains on the towels
they work i used to do that they work
when i got into a hotel dude i would
find myself completely naked people talk
about this all the time there's some
type of uh i feel free i think it's like
a um it's like a rental car yeah yeah i
treat it like i'm going over bumps
someone's driving him he's in the
passenger seat
that would be such a great service if
they had like a nude vehicle for you
just get in the back and it's getting
new you just get to be back here
oh they do it's called the bang bass i
think it's just called it's called the
bang boss that's a real thing it's just
uber but if people knew you were naked
it would be sick yeah let's take a
little break from the boys crystalia ear
griffin theo von the rat king and myself
because man whether it's saving more and
spending less getting organized or
losing weight there's a lot of
worthwhile goals to set for yourself
this year tell you right now top my list
is learning a new language with babel
yeah i'm trying to learn spanish man my
entire family speaks spanish but i don't
i'm also 38 years young so it ain't easy
but babel makes it super easy they've
sold over 10 million subscriptions not
only is learning a new language fun and
an engaging new hobby you can use it
while you check off traveling more from
your list the whole battle process is
fun fast it's super easy babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use not like we're in high
school we're talking about real world
use here son
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
a.i for their lesson plans but not babel
nope over 100 language experts in actual
accents not some robot telling you what
to say we're talking on real accents man
uh with babble you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian german whatever you want
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve
everything you're doing with your accent
man start your new language learning
journey today with babel plus it comes
with a 20 day money back guaranteed all
right right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription you get
additional three months free that's six
months for the price of three just go to
babel.com use the promo code k-a-t-s
that's babel b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code is k-a-t-s babble language for life
springtime is almost here i'll tell you
what as a dad not your dad one thing
that i admire most out of other dads is
a green lawn man you gotta keep it green
i love the smell of fresh cut grass some
of y'all don't have the proper grass you
ain't doing it right man thankfully
sunday gets your lawn grown and helps
keep it healthy all season long all
right sunday can help you grow a
beautiful lawn without the guesswork or
the nasty chemicals all you have to do
is visit getsunday.com put in your
address and their lawn
expert all right expert tools does the
rest they use soil and climate data to
create a personal nutrient plan
so it's basically steroids for your
grass delivered to your door when you
need it just attach the ready-to-use
pouch to the garden hose and spray away
takes less than 15 minutes boom green
lawn son all your neighbors will be so
jelly best of all this stuff really
works and sunday is offering the
kingston listeners and viewers 20 off
full season plans start just 129
buckaroos you get 20 off at checkout
when you visit getsunday.com
sting20 that's s t i n g 20 that's 20
off your custom plan at getsunday.com
sting20
yeah
yeah people knew about looking at the
car like holy [ __ ] that guy's naked it'd
be such a cool yeah
you went to the super bowl
yeah dude
yeah i know that's
you have two children wondering what
their dad's doing and he's working go to
the super bowl you idiot they don't want
to go to the super bowl man
you went there oh who's that theo
they're taking them out
don't see it bro you don't maybe you
would in asian countries but i don't
know no they don't do that
there's too much
getting your dick ain't a big asian
thing because of you
you
know
it's a big deal for them
but also but also like in this culture
too it's like a lack of respect to do
that i'm assuming that guy has a splash
of american in him i bet he's not full
of crap
yeah he's an american no he's not
full-on they'd never seen it would you
guys think when you saw that did you see
that eric yeah i saw it i thought to
myself uh theo's gonna get canceled
again for uh asian oh really not me i
was like squid game too looks lit that's
supporting asians dude yeah it reminded
me of cable guy and the gang was ah
they were aged
but you're saying it's equality you know
if there's going to be streakers there's
got to be all walks of life well i think
it's brave to see other people doing
stuff that other camp i mean that guy's
the cooper cup of [ __ ] streaks
basically i got tackled a ton in that
one too
that's racist
well it was cats in a while yeah yeah
it looks like me though
was he
completely i mean
i mean
does he look like you yeah
was he completely new on him quick man
that's the other thing that wasn't even
the you didn't even know about that on
the watching the feed no they didn't get
no promotion off of it they didn't know
anything that's good i like that because
they want to get like a sometimes it's a
big white dude who's athletic a big
black guy and the security has problems
like got this asian guy pretty yeah but
what was the guy recently they he
tackled him right remember when that
happened in the 49ers
yeah the guy's in his biggest game of
his life and some idiot wants to go oh i
agree no don't keep doing that yeah i
think [ __ ] [ __ ] you know who should
beat it [ __ ] didn't you see at the
football game hawkeye that should be
[ __ ] pick him out right there just
jeremy redder
yeah
was a little tipsy and he was like the
field goal kick and he was like if i had
my bow
i have my bow right now i [ __ ] love
that dude dying i love it he can
actually shoot a bow and arrow oh yeah i
love how that does
i love how that dude does fame he's just
like hey man locked out i mean he's very
he's very talented but you don't need to
be talented to make it you're lucky if
you make it whether you're talented or
not yeah and he's just like along for
the ride dude i love that dude i love
that dude he was in a funny you know was
funny he had a 49ers
nfc championship shirt ready to put on
if they won he had it ready to put on so
he was like i was like put your shirt on
homie
put it on he was cool dude that was
crazy yeah man that whole that whole
game was nuts man who'd you go with i
went with um
this guy todd graves he runs chain
kane's chicken
you know i'm talking about it yeah and
uh dude it was crazy we got in this
sprint or like michael thomas was there
the receiver um
yeah the receiver who else
uh we got in this sprinter so one of the
jonas brothers was there john um the
talented one of the jason the weird one
that plays the base yeah todd graves
right there inviting me my friend cam
fordham invited me so
kim's there his wife
who's in
stark county you know what i'm talking
about
and who else dude oh joel beckham's
brother okay then one of the guys from
uh crew huh yeah
but we get stuck to our car gets lost
from the we had like a police it was
crazy dude it was crazy we had a police
escort our car gets lost with one of the
guys from um
three's company or something what's that
damn with harry styles this is crazy no
no one direction wonders company
zane from three's company for you
uh so anyway we all get stu
so then we all just walk into through
regular entrance wow
i wonder about that yeah and nobody
noticed uh
so big oh he's yeah i didn't i didn't
know who i just didn't know i don't know
a lot of that music right in that
universe but and nobody noticed a thing
bro it was almost shawn mendes it was
like a science experiment
the best part about that would have been
somebody would have been like with all
those famous people been like
theo gang gang oh
yeah because you because but that's what
yeah like security's our fans yeah so
like
well that happened but people are
expecting to see us
yes they're actually shocked they were
expecting to see it was just bro it felt
like an element like a prank on the
ellen uh show
it really because you just go through
and you're just standing there other
people it's just like the whole thing
felt so strange the cops would not let
us go through like
a regular way yeah people know rat king
no yeah
the cops yeah rocking stay back lifted
up his shirt and he had a [ __ ] uh
what's your thing called life rips on it
wait hold on so so you went to the game
with all these famous people right yeah
how how
was it fun yeah it was crazy bro nelly
was in there okay france montana was in
there france montana ah
francis yeah
but the whole thing was it made no sense
i'm like who knows all these people but
when someone is chicken it has to be a
weird vibe though because none of you
are but that's what i'm saying okay so
here's the thing so here's the thing
hold on like when somebody gets to a
certain level of fame okay which you are
all of a sudden not no no i'm saying
you're at the level whatever that level
is i'm not saying you know obviously
there's the rock and then there's you
know well french montana and shawn
mendes i'd say like if the rock's at ten
they're nine yeah yeah yeah yeah right
and you're not as famous as shawn mendes
but you're at a level where now you're
invited to these things and the reason
why you're invited to these things is
because of that level of fame right i
mean you are a great guy but they don't
know that they're just like he's funny i
i have a i have a point to make here
okay the difference is comics
when when a big chicken rich chicken guy
yeah he can go
hey let's invite theo no i i will be
like comics will most likely be like
yeah dude i went to the game and i'm in
the game with like here's jimmy renner
tommy lee i understand ty dollar sign is
over here so yeah but because the guy
was a fan of mine i know i understand
that but there but what i'm saying is if
you're a fan of sean mendes you can't
just invite sean mendes to the game i'm
saying it has to do with a fame thing i
get that that's why they invited theo
but my point is you're with all these
people now you're with [ __ ] nelly
whoever the [ __ ] you don't do you
do you you don't care that they're
famous right i know you you don't really
care about them he's posting pics with
them on the right but that's all for
instagram
right yeah
i would probably do the same thing
yeah but
i was just i didn't know
like i'm talking to michael thomas who's
like my favorite like you know the best
and the best receiver well not the best
i like uh he's in the top five and just
having like just good just normal
conversations and we're all kind of
stuck together so and nobody's publicist
or nothing was there so it was just but
you guys all relate to like you're in
this bubble of faith to me it's weird to
me it makes me feel safe
like french montana doesn't have to
worry about you being like ah french
what's up dude grab them right because
you're all yeah level nobody let me
that's my level of the playing field
because everyone like kanye has shitty
seats it's it's just like when i see
when i see somebody that but no hold on
when i see somebody like the rock post a
picture with shawn mendes or [ __ ]
whoever the [ __ ] my brother and you're
like you they don't know it you're not
jewish it's annoying as [ __ ] yeah i if
if if i ever get to that level of fame
and i understand i'm at a level but if i
get to a level of like the rock or
whoever the [ __ ] and you see me starting
to post pictures with those
[ __ ] like they're my friends no
that you will never see it but you will
you will never see what the rock did he
buzz a picture of sean menendez went my
brother and then two minutes later went
not my brother actually yeah oh i just
made that up not really no i made that
up because that's why i did the rogue
okay okay i did zone out when the rock
started talking out there i kind of
zoned down a little bit i could feel the
whole setting be like
it's like when somebody all of a sudden
is in a hit movie and then all of a
sudden they're friends with everybody
they're friends with dave chappelle
they're friends with the [ __ ] and
they're all you're invited to those
parties weird celebrities
chase can't do that [ __ ] man [ __ ] all
that yeah well it was interesting
because i couldn't tell like uh i just
didn't even know i don't know man you
thought you're gonna hang out with the
guy that makes chicken yeah i thought i
was going with my buddy todd and he just
know he's friends with a lot of young
people so then if he introduces you to
he's like hey this is my friend this
this is my friend this so then you just
get in a conversation yeah and then we
were together literally the whole it was
like eight we got there at 11 and we
didn't get back home until 10 so it was
11 hours all together it's a long time
how about this how about this this is
the real thing
how many of these like
middle-aged
rich white guys how they're in the mix
with all these type of what do you mean
because i'm saying like give me an
example well this guy oh that runs the
chicken chicken guy like the chicken
guy's just like he's not famous
no i know but that's the real like you
know but that but it's the same thing
man
yeah did you get the championship game i
was with these guys
why
i don't know why you're not that guy
what no i don't know i guess i feel
weird talking about i feel like i'm like
set like maybe i shouldn't have said
anything about it no well
it's all over social media who cares
yeah right like you're not saying
anything bad
what's interesting
it was interesting i ended up honestly
just having a great time man got some
numbers of people that were like that i
was fans of didn't know about and it it
was interesting since there was no
publicist around that everybody kind of
just relaxed and then we were the last
people to leave the stadium everybody
else had gone we're just waiting and so
we
like we waited about two and a half
hours maybe yeah and then left out and
it was uh you went to a great super bowl
party yeah yeah yeah yeah it was just
crazy but the whole thing and it was
like some everybody walks by there's
some lady in a wheelchair i think people
just left yeah you know i don't know if
that's like a mexican thing or not but
there's like an older mexican lady and
she was just like yelling about the rams
you know yeah yeah
she leave one of us here every every
year she's young about the raiders she
just started screaming about nelly bro
and singing uh hot in here oh wow i'm
sure you love that he did just post that
video on accent him getting his dick
sucked he did
he was like that's my bat he deserves it
though dude he did so much for
white people wanting to
no he dance a point and he does tour
with florida georgia line so he did so
when at a time when white people were
like we're never going to be able to do
it for nelly's induction into the rock
and roll hall of fame it would be
theoretical
definitely go to that party or hang out
with jeremy renner but i'm telling you
man i've been around a ton of people
nobody shuts a room down i don't care
who you're around what big celebrities
nobody gets more attention shuts a room
down like mike tyson
nobody everyone just because remember
how big he was he's a scary dude even
though now he's on all the shrooms and
wheat in the world so he's a great dude
but
he walks in and i'm where the thing i
host that show on mike tyson's channel
and thick boy it was at lenny kravitz
house
in the hills this huge [ __ ] house
there's all these people there you
dropped something yeah i know he got
paid for it but he's dropping over yeah
will also drop the mexican woman in a
wheelchair you understand so he
everybody's equal with things i'm
telling man a room full of pretty famous
people mike tyson walks in everyone it
goes silence and it's like walking a
[ __ ] tiger through the goddamn party
no one just stares at me there's a
tattoo on his face there's like this
there's like this scary because he might
eat somebody you know but he might not
but you know but you've seen him do it
you've seen him eat someone's ears so
you're like oh wow when he was coming
down the mountain i was in vegas one
time and i'm getting a delta flight home
and literally mike tyson is just sitting
at the gate reading the newspaper wow
just at it you know waiting for the
looking at a newspaper
whatever he was doing it might have been
upside down on
uh the views expressed by these white
boys when he comes and storms in here
yeah but you know but i just thought he
just was like sitting there and
everybody literally everybody in the
gate area was just looking at him like
this
what [ __ ] mike tyson
hope people do that who else you think
i'm mr holt i'm lester holt the guy from
the
there's no top lip
the the guy from the like dateline [ __ ]
yeah mike thomas right there dude and
the saints reposted you i think that's
the coolest thing about your entire
experience you got reposted by your
favorite cool man big deal i'm and
was in there though it was just [ __ ]
it was the weirdest thing because at
first it was just like a few people and
then the i think other people just oh
one thing about the sweets i noticed
people you could walk into any suite i
walked into one on accident it was fedex
right it was all good oh dude you're
chilling and then there's like a little
like glass like this between the next
one and drake was standing right there
drinking a uh soda
so it was like nine white guys you know
because that's who fedex is right
yeah you get what you get the cardboard
is a brown front yeah once you get past
the packaging it's [ __ ] white as [ __ ]
yeah but it's it's six white guys around
that [ __ ] but your shit's always on
time
it's not always on time but anyway and
drake was literally so like i've made
eyes with like how where you could just
walk in it was just like there's i don't
know the whole thing i don't think felt
like i was in a different universe
but everybody probably felt safe too
because it's not like [ __ ] that no it's
like it's a super bowl everybody's
creepy bro you know what it is it's
creepy dude it's creepy they're having a
great super bowl party that's creepy bro
i've been to those parties it's creepy
as [ __ ] it's weird i don't like real l.a
vibes such la [ __ ]
this motherfucker's talking about
football with lenny kravitz bro
oh i'm sure that was fun brendan right
yeah let me say it who the [ __ ] wants to
do that who wants to do that who wants
to talk about the super bowl with lenny
[ __ ] kravitz what do you got to get
slapped are you gonna go for it
i think crap is hate coming from i don't
hate lenny kravitz but who the [ __ ] was
[Laughter]
suck on him on one of his braids was he
[ __ ] a savant or navajo
of course he was an artist he loved him
and he had a great time
[Laughter]
of course he did of course he did but
i'm telling you
[ __ ] that dude it was a [ __ ] girl i
know that at least i made money and best
friend i would have done it for racks
yeah but all i'm saying is this could
turn into opportunities for him
collect them racks dude get that kleenex
money who gives a [ __ ] but all i'm
saying is
who wants to do it
that's true dude it's like another job
it's like [ __ ] delivering people he
got offered to do what was that thing
you i got offered to uh watch a uf
bellator fight with a babe pig in the
city and he [ __ ] did it with 30 grand
bro
do it collect the wreck stack the money
pyramid to the sky
who watched that dude
sell out faces
no i had a great time
the show's my idea they bought my show
hey can you put a phone number up right
now underneath brenda's name i can be
bought at one eight hundred oh by the
way i can be bought yo can we bought it
so can you hear but it's nobody buying
me son
for the free chicken and that's it
you know i'm sending chris at a super
bowl party at his house and it's shitty
amazing who came to it
a bunch of people man
uh no
uh lenny grabbed it
i mean kind it was kind of a it was get
together you don't watch football so you
just need to excuse that people yeah it
was birthday is going to be on friday so
we were like okay we'll be calvin's
birthday but also we'll do it on the
super bowl but we'll do one of those big
white like kind of like crazy birthdays
with not really no we had like uh what
do you call them soft play things come
you did it before right with your kids
like the the yeah the mexican president
or whatever [ __ ] exactly yeah yeah it's
like ninja it was cute
he's going to be doing the road yeah
yeah
um calvin's jeremy renner yeah yeah
um yeah yeah he's doing the road yeah
that
yeah
he's gonna be dead i'm in omaha i know
what y'all do for uh valentine's day my
girl was in um um
new york doing fashion week
oh so i was rich rich too i'm sick of
you guys
models don't make any money unless
they're the the like the top five is
that true yeah bro
bottles
dude there's like one male model that
made one million dollars one year at one
time yeah it's hilarious dude male
models
dude but the male models are chairs the
girls just sit on them and the guy's
like imagine being a male model
though i'm telling you i'm telling you
i'd rather be a [ __ ] crack [ __ ]
that's the worst [ __ ] job in the
world just sit there you got to be dumb
as rocks the way you grew up i'm the
most one of the more handsome comedians
right now you changed most to one of the
more i don't like it but dude i'll tell
you this man
bro and by the way no i support him him
[ __ ] all that
when i get on stage you think there
aren't people that are like all right
bro i got a [ __ ] level up my
personality dude i gotta keep cursing me
what the [ __ ] are you kidding coming
from the ugly guy dude
yeah
it's supposed to look like a [ __ ]
cute [ __ ]
this [ __ ] the mulch what makes him sexy
exactly you look like [ __ ] cruella de
vil's gynecologist
you are not handsome i i accept that i
am not handsome he's got a rugged
handsome thing
let's ask the guy who it actually is
that knows this [ __ ] because he's been
him for 41 years what the deal is the
deal is all of the features i have
aren't necessarily attractive i get it
my nose my eyes my mouth your forehead
you could argue for my mouth on my
forehead my hair you could argue for my
forehead or my mouth but all the other
features they're not good if you put
them on other people's but the way they
come together on mine and the way i
[ __ ] let the line shine through out
of it
i may not be hot but boy is there
something about me dude yeah and you
know it it's like it's that it's the
outfit it's gold that's the x factor and
that's way better than being a [ __ ]
chair you know that's way better than
being good
you think yeah exactly some people are
good looking and have the x factor me i
figured it out that's why models and
tick tock people start to do stand up
yeah i know because they think they can
do it they think they have the [ __ ] x
factor but they don't they have it with
their phone that's the super easiest way
to have the x factor but in person show
up
show up whenever eric whenever whenever
eric had gone after me or it would be go
like brian me and eric eric on stage
like [ __ ] them this is what stand up
looks like
single time this is what it's supposed
to look like [ __ ] that does good man he
does well he does do well if you like
that comedy here we go
[Laughter]
you do well if you want to hear the
subtext of racism
that's your comedy
so it's a safety it's a fun race it's
hip-hop racism
that might be the title
gotta have a little bub you gotta have a
little man let's take another little
break man because
life is crazy out there man you don't
have time to run the grocery store get
those essentials whatever you're looking
for men my friends at grubhub listen
they can deliver in 30 minutes or less
30 minutes or less grubhub is promoting
the recent launch owned convenience
offering grubhub goods grubhub goods
it's all new man
whether you're a gamer podcaster you're
binge watching your favorite show you
don't have time for this stuff and this
episode of king and the sting is
sponsored by grubhub all right from
extras to essentials grubhub now
delivers all of your go-to convenience
items all day long through their own
convenience store grubhub goods that's
right it's grubhub goods with the late
night snack paper towels can of soda
convenience items all delivered right to
your door just in the nick of time and
you never have to leave home in your
undies order your convenience items from
grubhub goods on the app or online how
long you want to carry this bit going
dude i've all look i don't know
here's what does it for chris that helps
him out
and you don't have it and you you you
might have it
he has a
he has a length of neck that i do not
have if i had an extra half inch of neck
for comedy the booty doesn't really help
for comedy yeah is the best ass in
comedy you just i turn around you hear
this half the crowd like look at that
yeah yeah what they stopped they just
stopped laughing right there you're
trying to stretch your neck out and i
used to do that business plus no daddy
you look like how you're gonna look as
an old man yeah doing that no and that
and that picture is the guy who's
blowing you took it
it was a
female guy
and that's the noise that's the face
that you make when
[Music]
and you're so excited for him to do it
i can't live like that anymore it's so
funny everybody's attractive in their
own way nope not dude
then what's up then what's up ugly is a
word that's a thing then who's ugly if
it exists then somebody's ugly listen
man it is what you see inside people's
hearts and souls they would i think you
would you'd see that people some people
aren't but we can't yeah but we can't so
features this is all [ __ ] you see
the heart parts are ugly hearts are so
ugly that you had to draw them different
you draw them like this
everyone's heart's [ __ ] ugly as [ __ ]
yeah damn
you know what i mean i just look i came
here to speak the truth i'm sorry if it
hurts anyway we should probably start
the show
what you got nick
oh yeah
theo
that's not bad
bad guy free air
in that picture right there that's
probably the same age as your dad right
here but like but no no thirty years
later he has
free air dude
all right what's up with this kick in
this thing fat yo what's up king of the
sting fam brendan theo chris and
whoever's in the building it's your boy
summers from hyderabad india wow i've
got a debate club for you guys
russia trilogy or bad boys trilogy which
one is it good question
was better though
i think it was yeah i think it was
better too you know russia i think so no
maybe not the first bad boys was great
but then after that the second one was
lit miami no i forgot the second one
despicable me was better than all of
them i thought
well yeah
it's great come on one two and three
doug
listen i'll take tango in cash overall
oh yeah dude you know what i'm saying i
know theo he's basically [ __ ] what
that's basically me and theo in a way
it's if you mix tango and cash
i'm kidding so you're stallone in this
yeah or i guess it could be him yeah you
wouldn't be stallone you'd be the other
guy
oh no you're the nerdy guy he'd be more
corrupt no yeah look look look it's
actually brendan
but chris you could be the nerdy guy who
builds the truck but i don't want to be
that guy all right i'm just spitting on
ideas there's only three rules i don't
want to be him i know but you know be
the bad guy be the bad guy you have to
be here is the bad guy cool yeah yeah
bring him up the back again does he have
an accent he looks like barry switzer oh
gru you mean
no let me see him
what was the best movie of all the
franchises put together between rush
hour and you see the bad boys which
what's the best movie then we'll pick
that one as well rush hour one and bad
boys two that's barry switzer and that
could be you
i like that guy yeah jack that guy looks
like jack palance yeah that is jack
palin yeah who is that he's the owner of
the dallas cows that's him no that's the
bad that's the bad guy
that's jack palance that guy seemed like
a good guy
oh that's funny yeah wow okay
so that's probably the best trilogy
i'm saying what is the best movie of all
the in the trilogy oh man terminator 2.
i think no no i'm talking about
transformation
oh got it okay which one would what's
your favorite
one or uh bad boys two no
better i like bad boys too bad boys one
is what set will smith off man it made
him one was best i thought he made him a
superstar he wouldn't dude russia with
chris the two other side characters in
bad boy were [ __ ] hilarious which one
the the the the latino dude yeah they
were so funny oh they were good with
cops when they picked up the phone one
of these stories they picked on point
economy is like hey what's going on yeah
your mama sniffed it all up last night
anyway like dude just like for no reason
like we don't even know what he said
exactly that's why we're at their best
um
but yeah no no i i think uh for sequels
nothing beats terminator 2 though right
i think
no godfather two
okay but we're talking about we're
talking about action movies i mean
godfather okay yeah of course ant-man
did y'all like it no uh-huh no no not
the sequel no good sequels man paul
rudd's
yeah if he i wouldn't know if he was
dead or alive
no actually confuse him and your boy
isn't he at your
[Laughter]
they're trying to you know yeah yeah i
bet i could get them
little worse hot dogs there dude they
had those long [ __ ] how about you
deep down they're gonna make hot dogs
but instead of get get a regular hot pot
i'm with you i don't want the shots
sticking out of the bunker
i want to eat the bread with the meat
right that's what we're saying that's
what we're saying no but this i don't
want to have to step off the end but you
know what's good though making friends
you eat the middle and the two guys cute
lady in the trunk see i like i brought
myself
they used to be the dodger dogs yeah and
then he's been a dodger dog for like 30
years and then relocated now he just
makes hot dogs at that so
yeah made it up you don't know that to
be true
i don't believe that yeah try it i would
never but that's a conspiracy
deep throwing that hot dog though i does
for my own some of the food one thing
that they didn't have was good was this
little cupcake little black cupcake with
some little um
kind of a cream feature like a sushi
sushi cake
no i know my stadium food dog like a
ding-dong it tasted bad but more high a
little bit higher than a ding-dong drink
drinking
there's a certain level of dessert and
food like hot dog ding dong the highest
level is under the highest level you
should never have a higher level of the
of what it is because that's exactly
what that is the second you try to
gourmet it up it gets worse yeah and
that is the truest [ __ ] i ever spoke
okay
he's doing a lot of magic and he's not
saying anything no i am saying complete
utter reality see how he's doing it yeah
because you're talking i get it i'll sit
on my hands
yeah any time he starts trumping that's
the challenge
it is
this is fantastic listen dude it's the
[ __ ] here we go we're right in here
we're in this [ __ ] do it can you do
it let me try to still be inspirational
without the [ __ ] okay okay
there is a certain level oh i've seen
this guy speaks at churches i just use
my neck more there is a certain level
no your adam's apple has to no there's a
certain level of ding-dong that it
should never supersede you agree with me
that's the whole thing it's like it's
indonesia brownies are duncan hines if
you go to a place that makes gourmet
brownies you're you've and i say this
not lightly you've lost your mind and
you've lost your way seriously because
duncan hines they kill it
he speaks at churches that's the dude
and he's amazing too wow what he lacks
in arms he makes up for in beard oh wow
no this guy wait wait he's just sitting
indian style it's a magic show i thought
he had no legs too i'm like that's too
much i think you know there's some
something wrong with this deformity his
legs yeah oh yeah he's got limited legs
oh yeah what makes you say that
the fact that his feet are in his penis
don't you just think he's great at yoga
yeah that's what i thought i thought he
was just no you know what he did he
didn't think that i did i thought he was
like that was really stupid he's just
little those big toes in his armpit yeah
well he doesn't have an armpit but yeah
that guy's an amazing speaker actually
yeah well i i don't mean to be a dick
but like
yeah but you know daredevil
can't can't see but he can see you've
got to be better
with things you don't have oh yeah your
other senses grow stronger yeah yeah
yeah so you bet you you could be good so
you're taking it so you're taken away
from i'm not trying to take away from
i'm just trying to speak you're
basically taken away no i'm not trying
to take it away from you some arms bro
and they do the same thing that's what
you're saying that should be life
without limbs right
but i'm telling you
i'm telling you
that would be a little
hey why is his foot buried in the sand
it looks like a little kid's foot
now i'm going to go to hell because i'm
over here for this couch
this is the hardest yeah this is what
i'm saying the two things you left
the two things you laughed at the
hardest that uh that i said in the last
skin of this thing with the [ __ ] life
without limbs joke and the lady with the
[ __ ] forehead back you're going to
hell
i want to see those two do it like like
a motivational couple
eric's like that hospital
orderly that comes in at night and just
makes fun of everybody
he's gonna lose your job
but it's like a coma people and i'm just
like look at your fat ass
i don't know man here's the thing in a
coma [ __ ] god bless this dude he's
killing it
don't try to limit no no i'm just saying
without limb i'm not saying the guy
wrote a book i mean he said to write a
shirt
all i'm saying is this guy you think you
you want he wants to be made fun of just
like we want to be made fun of this is
the thing about [ __ ] you everybody
gets these jokes no no way nobody cannot
can i say something what you're saying
right now is like yes you have like no
arms so should we put you in a bubble or
should we clown me like we would clown
anyone else that's making you a part of
society but it's like yeah exactly and
like what are we gonna make fun of his
teeth yeah they're beautiful yeah the
guy's got no arms it's actually handsome
from here up yeah no [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying yeah like if i didn't know
all that other [ __ ] was going on if it
was like dark and you just had a
spotlight on his face you'd be like
he can get onto a table a four foot
table with no help boom and that's him
too go to the other pitcher that's him
go back oh this is doing well now that's
him too
oh hold on don't go with this
killing it
opened up the ark of the covenant and
he's starting off
do you know what i mean he's killing it
nick vujicic i want to write a book i
didn't write a book would you guys want
to talk to nico just sick on the future
king of the sting or wow
is that the guy with the arms yeah what
if he just is like and your
[ __ ] ruined my life and chris
and eric you are going to hell oh i
would be really sad but you have to play
this clip of us laughing at him and then
see what he has to say we're laughing
with him eric
i don't know i've seen him speak before
he's a great speaker he's very inspiring
i cried how many times you cried why
they didn't have the right food they
didn't have his right well we have to
ask what did you do before you went to
the thing though
or something yeah were you on something
yeah listen to anya and took sharon's
house with a senior citizen theo's on
show like man this guy's no harm that'll
make you cry yeah in the
of an angel
he totally can't sing that song hey but
but is he he is it's a he's a religious
speaker motivational
girl
can you see what this guy's yeah
i never want to see what a guy that
looks like first of all this is
obviously a chris d'alia fan dude that
is indian he is great he's a christian
you clown our fans that is crystal that
is a crystal effect this guy i'll tell
you what if i hadn't been coming on the
show he wouldn't be doing a video here
so let's see what he has to say cool
jacket though first of all i just want
to say wow thank you for the compliment
on the attire
right as you can see it came in this
thing
i don't know if you can see the king and
sting is on the background that is saved
by the debate of the day you have two
options
um he's in the tuck shop the first one
cool all your text messages between your
buddies your group chats
are released in the public for
everyone's association
i
or option number two is
you smell like cat piss but
you don't know no i watch the first one
100 i choose for the first one to get
out well someone in here
but hold on a second how did they we
didn't even take into account how
incredible it was that i said i like
that jacket and then he started off the
video by saying thanks for the
compliment on my attire well because he
knows a lot do you know he looks really
good you know he looks ridiculous but
that's insane the guy's a bot dude all
right well whatever he maybe he's a bob
put that on for that reason that's fun
no this guy wears that trust me
trust me i know yeah he didn't just yeah
it's his [ __ ] but he knew every day but
hold on like seems like a good guy yeah
yeah that's his tuck shop he owns that
in uh jonesborough alabama oh nice oh
damn a lot of business out there have
you seen jasper mall it's about a mall
that's shutting down mm-hmm
of course not no
is it a documentary is the documentary
it's good oh really if you like like a
closing mall yeah is that like is that
nashville public access
is this exciting
it's on hulu or one of the other
streamers i'm not sure but it's about a
closing mall in jasper alabama
the more mundane a thing a documentary
is about the better the documentary and
let me tell you why because it has to be
just like that guy has to be a good
speaker when he has no limbs it's the
same [ __ ] thing you gotta oh this is
the thing that we really got if you're
gonna make a [ __ ] documentary about a
closing mall it can't be like century
city bro it's gotta be good
have you seen the
tinder swindler oh man it's okay but
that guy's still out there it's okay
you've uh i've never seen anything like
it i've never heard of that oh man
there's so many [ __ ] 2020s that are
the same thing it happens all day
brenden you don't that's the thing about
you sometimes man it's like here we go
oh go ahead well it just doesn't he
doesn't know where he lives man you live
in like an alternate universe
interesting you don't think this kind of
[ __ ] happens every day it's happening to
me right now
yeah you're out of your mind what i
don't get is how is he not in prison he
did go to borrowed money for five months
he borrowed money yeah he yeah he's like
i borrow money and he technically simon
dude how bad and some of the girls that
gave him millions of dollars they're hot
i'm like girl go get a [ __ ] regular
dude it's weird yeah he'll get his when
he dies
yeah yeah take it up with the devil son
am i right if i got you don't believe it
but yeah you know i don't know if i got
tin tinder swindled um
he'd to me if some if a guy tinder
swindled me did you ever get catfished
ever oh yeah yeah i mean like
yeah i mean but what do you mean like
have i like what what is so what catfish
is responding and thinking it's someone
else and then realizing it's not oh then
yeah yeah everyone has it right yeah
but i mean like have you ever tried to
like meet up with somebody
i talked to this lady on the phone and
it was a man it was a gay man it's a gay
black man okay so it was facetime
no you just heard the blackness but what
did you think
sometimes asian people can go anyway
these days you know these days yeah but
in the oj case that's what [ __ ]
what's his name uh uh the ron henry no
uh close
the ron his name's ron no no the racist
guy no no the the the not the judge the
lawyer the johnny cochran he was saying
like because somebody said it sounded
like a black man and o.j is black and he
was like that is racist you can't tell
you know what i mean and it's like when
johnny cochran said it he sounded black
and he's a black guy you can hear when
somebody's back
but can you still that's getting
different it is getting it is going to
give her but that's because there's a
lot of people mixing racism right yeah
well i mean it's also where you're from
who you talk to 100 percent there's
nolan richardson right now but what i'm
saying is that you so your first thing
was you got on the phone after been
texting and texting texting so your
first thing was this person is black or
this person is a man this person is a
man probably both great
[ __ ] question if it was the other one
you're racist
yeah but but you you could tell it was a
gay
racist a gay black man oh no that's not
it's the it's the other things you've
done
and i'm not even racist dude a lot of
these people
are good people
okay i'm just chatting about it but you
get on the phone you were like you get
on the phone you're like hold on hold on
hold on you ain't you you're not white
[Music]
oh really it was like yeah the big guy
get a big terry cruise yeah
i'm ready to be black too in my next
life um yeah do it though you got to ask
for it go train thank you yeah what did
you like
at what point huh with your first
interaction you were just like oh come
on no i talked for a minute or two i
just felt bad for the guy a little bit
good for you that's very theory to talk
for a minute that's sort of a panera
bread and i was kind of late for an
appointment mm-hmm
a bread appointment good evening guys
oh wow that's good that's no like you're
proper i like it yeah i like that
professional good evening guys welcome
to a very special time for announcements
[Music]
king the sting and the wing we're
hitting patreon son yup tell them chris
march 10th march 10th is the episode
that drops that is exclusive for patreon
what are we doing two on patreon and two
free on youtube that's right yeah so
that's the deal from now on yeah um it's
called the takeover yep so every other
week will be patreon every other week
will be
on youtube um and why are we doing it
guys we're gonna pull our [ __ ] a little
bit more uh we're gonna be on patreon
there's gonna be no ads on there yeah
because the ads they sometimes sometimes
the truth is the ads kind of
they they they
they just i don't know they get upset if
you don't do certain stuff some of it
you just i don't want to deal with yeah
we get it just fighting back you're
getting crystallia theovonne and my
stealth and myself king the sting and
the wing buzz buzz gang gang shore
yeah i hate panera bread honestly
who likes it more who likes it more than
your girl though you know what i mean my
bro what is it about the [ __ ] nobody
likes it no
from someplace else
i know it's not even it's not even it's
not even like single girls it's like a
girl that has a boyfriend loves panera
dude yeah they want to get out and go
get the bowl and [ __ ] i want to say
panera it makes it sound like it's
fantastic like you're going somewhere
my mom told me as a kid you called
target target yeah yeah
it's annoying but honestly though
panera bread how about
panera bread panera means [ __ ] bread
right so basically it's just bread bread
bread let's go to bread yeah that's
awesome go to bread gang gang i have a
question for you guys all gun can suck
my dick too i have a question
or once did you
i got so my girl was away i picked her
up last night and i got her a
valentine's card
you know and then i from like ralph's
were you talking about yeah i went to
like violence on the way you know what i
mean
card is saying all my words yeah that's
why i picked the code that's why i
picked the card and she was like i know
but it's those are the cards words yeah
she has a point what are your words i'm
like you have a point brendan no no get
out
get out did you kick her out
get out did you get her chocolate too
eric yeah yeah yeah he ate half of them
sorry i ate all this
you gotta put the the fat correct but
that was like tourette's i didn't even i
wasn't even even even even even even
even meaning
that joke to reps
if you buy him you can have one i feel
like yeah i mean i tried it yeah dude i
just make her open them right away
i don't open it i just go let's open it
girl
before you read the card let's open
those chocolates
let's open it i've been thinking about
them all day that car sounds better if
you got a little chocolate
but she got me something from new york
she got me this eclair that said it says
i declare that i love you you know what
i said but those aren't your words
oh nice
good but though
yeah
luckily
just ice cream yeah just ice cream just
ice cream coffee
vanilla
until something comes out and then he's
doing it and then he'll say no no this
is what it is very big that is very mean
but ice cream though but ice cream
though ice cream dude ice cream i like i
like tyson i go to uh icing
bro that's i love ice cream like i'm
fine it's easy
i'll go to the mrs fields and i get two
warm chocolate uh cookies and i'll have
them put
two inches of vanilla ice in and like
that's fatty dude
i see them
once a week as a kid i say all my
money's terrible look at him it's just
ice cream's good i want other stuff too
that activates the sugar you know she's
icing just sugar
for three hours i know super bowl that's
terrible i don't think this guy is
facing five hours later still on
carnival
tiger king hey dude i want you know what
i thought about this last night while
going to sleep i want you to stop doing
the [ __ ] carnivore diet no way yeah
you know why because you can't keep
doing it you have to stop at some point
because you're gonna [ __ ] die dude
baby enjoy my time here dude shut up man
the way he did it he kind of made me
feel good and then took it away
you just [ __ ] you know
yeah
you want to get stabbed in the back i'll
stab you in the front bro
look in your eyes look at my eyes bro
there you go you'd rather that bro yeah
a hundred percent what's this young man
watching [ __ ] sneaky he needs some
advice
g'day guys uh ronald thompson here from
queensland australia oh yeah australia
forever advice for you guys
uh my miso likes to go on girls trips
and obviously i don't really like
attending those
makeup [ __ ] tutorial [ __ ]
[ __ ] storms i'm all good got some things
i'm fine
but when she wants to come when i'm on
the boys trips she wants to attend
am i a dig for saying
no i don't want you to come for them
because i don't come to yours or what
let us know gang gang buzz buzz
your feature brings his girlfriend's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing just
like the whole vibe just don't don't
you got this it's not just it's the
age-old thing it's like oh yeah like oh
man one time i was with
my ex and she was like um do you want to
have lunch with uh my friend and i and i
said
no
and she said what and i was like i just
don't want to and she said well i would
want to have lunch with you and your
friends and i said
my friends are the most entertaining
people in the world
actually yeah
it's not the same yeah
right at all yeah there's no good you
know by the way you know you don't have
to have fairness and everything either
yeah you don't have to have equality and
everything either yeah you don't have to
tell her well you go with your friends i
should go you just go no we don't want
any girls there no that's what's the
whole vibe up yeah we need yeah i don't
know
i don't know man i mean i don't mind
going out i don't like how you said that
sorry one day i will have somebody i
don't have somebody right now because i
don't have any i've been dating and
working on yourself yeah and i've been
dating mm-hmm
yeah there's nothing else to be mad at
then no i'm mad but oh yeah you seem to
want to fight you guys know this answer
better than i do this guy has a problem
i feel like i feel like um
there's just you know she wants that's
just what women most of the time
speaking generally want they want their
dude but do the other girls want their
dudes to be with them they're all having
the same argument too
you know what i mean he should just say
like what do your friends say oh wow
because you don't want to be the only
dude [ __ ] you don't want to be the only
dude [ __ ] this is you keep working out
brother but you don't want to be the
only
dude [ __ ] that is like brings your
chicken you bring your chick but worse
you don't want to [ __ ] up their [ __ ] the
girls don't the other girls don't really
want that guy there well not at all my
girl my girl has these her friends come
over and she's like would you want to be
here i was like no
i go seriously go to the basement
i'll be up in my office
they had the other night poor feelings
it's like what you need more of that
though but i do a lot of that now i talk
about my feelings a lot dude therapist
yeah i'll cry right now do you think my
therapist like rolls her eyes everywhere
my therapist is so good dude she is
unbelievable man everyone says that i
know bro oh wow have you guys started
[ __ ] no no
she's older you know what bro not
everything's a joke
he win you'll feel it there it is
she's just [ __ ] you know what she is
i don't ever say she's wonderful dude
that's good that's so strong she's great
i i i i definitely have more empathy and
the thing is here's the other thing i i
i hated like the other day i caught
myself listening to music
and i never listen to music and i never
listen to music because it makes me too
emotional and and i and i hated
accessing that part like if you turn on
[ __ ] david gray forget it dude i
would just leave me on hand leave me all
ahead light and [ __ ] tears down that
[ __ ] [ __ ] i know but but everything was
that right that's a good song and that
is a good song dude yeah babylon
leave me on it and that's not even as
good as he does it and so
and so i would listen to that in the car
and it would just break me down you got
to turn this [ __ ] off
exactly well you know when you're going
through a breakup though you turn on the
radio and all of a sudden everything's
like you know i used to love you every
song yeah yeah so i i get music is very
much i could i couldn't do it everybody
got one leg in a commercial now you
notice that i do notice that dude it's
horrendous bro
have you seen the new [ __ ] uh cheaper
by the dozen movie that they made on
disney plus bro it's like a black guy
and a girl and a a white guy and a black
guy get together and they have kids and
now this is the new version of cheaper
by the dozen they're not just white
people and then they open the door and
they're like hey hassan to one of their
indian kids i'm like how the [ __ ] did an
indian get in here it's just so woke and
there is somebody with only one leg in
that show everything unbelievable and um
don't even get me started no get started
oh yeah yeah because i talk about i've
been talking about some of this on stage
what are your favorite videos well you
got a great bit of yeah i love how in
the old days they put a dog before a
minority
look they put a dog before they know
that's how much they're racist but
here's what they're doing now though
here's what they're doing
they're still making it they're still
making [ __ ] all white like these
commercials everybody's still white but
like this huggies commercial the baby
got glasses
oh that's how they're doing it now yeah
that's a diversity yeah that's how they
diversity baby and my thing is like that
[ __ ] is distracting because how does
baby get glasses are they holding the
baby up and the doctor's like one
yeah or two yeah baby's in a little
wheelchair yeah like how's the baby
gonna [ __ ] the wheelchair comes out
with them it's like i don't so it's like
i don't get what's going on is that how
you wanna uh is that how you wanna sell
your product having people distracted
looking like do i need to send money
people probably aren't buying it man
everyone's afraid i just don't get it
man yeah anything remember the guinness
commercial with the dudes in the
wheelchairs playing basketball i don't
know and then at the end of it they're
like guinness oh yeah 80s like what the
[ __ ] that guy's probably got half of
them man hit by drunk driver i just i
just don't get it
that's blackish well yeah this has to be
it's not by the dozer no this is
blackish yeah yeah they let you know in
the title what this is about and there's
still that's what we have to do we got
to put it in the title it'd be
interesting if people sent in a video
and they just described themselves and
then there was a break and then they
told we got to guess who's who who's
staying there or whose fan they were oh
would that be a good idea or not nick i
think it would be a good idea yeah i
actually thought the same thing like a
few videos ago when we said that they
had about my thing i'm not saying i
thought of the idea first we both
thought about it independently but yes
it's a good
here's the commercial guys and it's all
sad the music's all sad it's powerful
boys if one of them dunked it would be
bad yeah i'd be sick
no but you want to make a man cry
you do sports this makes you want to
drink beer though disabled
oh this makes you want to what if at the
end of the day
even they play basketball even they even
they dream
so you're kind of like what is this
about no
loyalty there's no black guys no there
is
some butterscotch in there oh
well then they just
oh because there's one guy right yeah no
it's one guy they were doing it
that's cool that's pretty cool i like
that commercial honestly i know but then
it's about guinness yeah that's stupid
that's what i'm seeing it could be it
could be toyota it could be anything
how about not one funny super bowl
commercial oh hey i'll go beyonce how
about not one funny commercial ever
pretty much in the history of time how
about that true [ __ ] oh bro get
out of here that's super funny
commercial called a swear jar okay okay
i didn't see it wasn't good i saw
something you ran i don't know if it was
good it was funny
dude there are some but do you know how
easy and i mean
it is let me sit on my hands to make a
funny commercial it's extremely [ __ ]
easy it's not though because no don't do
it
dude they can't do it because there's so
much bureaucracy and red tape it's so
easy to do ruined austin powers and
cable guy two of the funniest things
ever it makes my point is if you can
make austin powers and you can make
cable guy two funny movies those are two
hours you can't make 30 seconds worth of
funny no you suck they didn't you suck
this is this eric's so funny commercial
right now
it's safety first now let's see eric's
commercial let's see i'm gonna be honest
with you and brennan's doing
drugs that's a swear jar every time
someone swears you put a quarter in it
he gets the money so far it's not funny
i don't know we'll use it to buy
something for the office like a
case of bud light or something
[ __ ] awesome
so far it's not good bob
[ __ ] you jim
how are you
really fat back then can i borrow your
pen
can i borrow your [ __ ] pen
you know what's funny well the owner of
a white station wagon please go for
yourself it's two
we're gonna go down there don't don't
don't [ __ ] see that
don't let these [ __ ] [ __ ] you
you laughed it was funny
it's too
[Music]
that commercial they didn't put
on the air for long they used it on the
internet it was before the new media
thing
so i was gonna tell you that was never
this was there was right after no did
that that commercial right afterwards
it was never on tv it's crazy it was for
they did but the thing the thing is it
was right after janet jackson's titty
popped out oh so they were like super
sensitive about everything but then this
is one of these things they were letting
people like share it share it share it
and and so we got this [ __ ] money
i always say
right there
jackson and justin timberlake owe me a
million dollars wow you should got a
little bread off that you're buried and
we also did like another commercial
after that the same concept but it was
like a clothing drive so we're all
walking around naked you got to get that
brand homie yeah i just think uh i'm
sorry yeah yeah yeah we could do another
one yeah
this is theo
hopefully chris so i can roast the [ __ ]
out of me but um
was jack i was wondering what you guys
think about this so
for my mullet hitter i don't use shampoo
or conditioner um
basically scrub my hair with tea tree
oil
and then once i'm done like once i get
another shower i'll mix coconut oil
moroccan oil is this everybody from
napoleon dynamite in one person
why does he sound like [ __ ] it's good i
mean
keeping this mullet hitter like nice and
[ __ ]
he's the dahmer glasses
[ __ ]
let me tell you something ante right now
he's boss no okay right now that guy's
disguising his ugliness he's disguising
his ugliness
the glasses the mullet the mustache see
his glasses are like
you know what i'm saying that somebody
can't see but they're looking good
this motherfucker's glasses are so thick
he can't even wear i bet you he can't
even get contacts his eyesight is so
[ __ ] you can get contacts you can
literally wear sunglasses let me tell
you something if that guy
cut his mullet shaved his mustache took
his glasses off guess what he is a six
no with that body he's a five or six
yeah what do you mean that guy looks
like a mustache it's disgusting no no no
no the mustache is what disguises his
ugliness so when the opposite sex sees
him they're like okay okay if they met
him without the mustache they'd be all
no way i'm telling you right now really
it's why theo got famous after his
mother [ __ ] mullet yeah dude i had
this you're talented and i was talented
people liked me you're very talented
that guy is very crap
and you should be famous and [ __ ]
have money yeah mullet helped you no way
don't you know what i see i had to
qualify it with all that [ __ ] yeah he's
saying
the mullet is everything i had another
special when i didn't have long hair
uh but netflix wasn't a big deal then no
no you found yourself bro you became you
you became a huge deal to get one though
they only gave out six yeah that's true
you became youtube bro
it was your destiny oh no i think it
could have been but it was also part of
my childhood so i think it was just a
return to it was destiny i think that
there's no one more than that you lose
yourself but you lose yourself you
should cut it off no no no no i think
honestly it suits you i don't i don't
even think of myself as that people i
don't
this is how i live now you're cool like
that don't cut it i don't know anything
else now chris you start going bald we
got problems
yeah have you seen his dad i might his
dad his dad is like a wizard yeah oh
yeah
isn't it i lost
for word yeah these wizards i i lost um
have you seen the washington wizards
yeah they're pretty good too i
lost started losing hair i lost hair
when i was like 36 and then it just
stopped and this is my hair now yeah
yeah but your dad has the same your
dad's i actually think i actually think
i have more hair than i did when i was
36 because i i started taking that [ __ ]
uh propecia yeah or whatever it is yeah
you know what it hold on
no mine's not called that mine's not
called finasteride yes that's what it is
it's finasteride prone code jobs vitamin
d it's pro
that's what i take it too it's cheaper
finesse riders yeah
but as it should be i think you don't
want to overpay for something why do you
use it you don't need i need it bro my
hairs get disappearing man yeah that's
crazy
such a fantastic head of hair
your hairline is in a dope spot it's
like pow it's going back you guys don't
theo's hairline is if me and chris had a
baby like mine i gotta worry about
running my eyebrows yeah yours [ __ ] is
way tight yeah my [ __ ] is i have a big
forehead yeah it's like people have the
smallest forehead in the world you guys
even know who people bryce oh i know who
people bryson is yeah you write down
people right the number one guy on one
of those [ __ ] when they used to sell
cds on commercials
yeah he would be there yeah yeah like it
was like you know
the summer jams
but he would be hosting the thing he'd
be like i'm people bryson and we are
yeah 100
he's the beauty and the beast guy
beautiful guy he's saying it with uh
celine dion oh i didn't know that i
don't i don't know him wow he's beauty
and the beast is that it nick that's it
that's it that was a long show yeah uh
oh no it's not bad how was it
wow
jesus uh where you boys at man i'm in
sacramento
october i'm sorry february 24th to 26th
march early march i'm in nashville
zany's march next shopping friends is
february 23rd wednesday 8pm hollywood
improv shopping friends some monsters so
then after that 24th 26th sacramento the
punchline there's 30 tickets left we
can't add show so that [ __ ] can sell
out so get them right now and then in
march i'm at zany's nashville early
march
and then i'm in chicago into march
oh god who's next
i'm in uh braya well it's sold out so
i'm in brea i added another show
it might be sold out by this one
one friday or something sunday i added
it on sunday um i'm gonna be there
oh eric's coming yeah i'm gonna be there
uh and then um
[Music]
and then i'm in irvine in april um
that's a long ways away i know but
that's this is my only date
yeah i don't have a lot of dates either
for some reason i'm going to calculate
now's the time to go man the mandates
are out there letting you do it i did i
just was in canada i just did it it was
fine i thought they were all shut down
with the trucks no they they got a
little slip they got a little uh
no masks or what yeah they're in there
with no masks wow i've been to canada
twice now i went to
edmonton and then i went to uh vancouver
and it was fine bro how about i was a
restaurant this morning and there used
to be strict on showing cards
and the the guy who owns it kind of you
know whatever 40s 50 years old and the
lady worked in the front this like group
of six came in and she's like uh can i
see your back sorry
stop that [ __ ] oh they're done with
[ __ ] hello
and he goes give me that sign rip the
side off the door i'm like whoa oh
that's whatever we just
third time yeah the third time the first
time he said he held his breath then
he's at the super bowl and now he's just
like [ __ ] third time yeah it's like do
you i don't even care if you believe in
it or not just do what you want us to do
yeah that's it's like some [ __ ] we just
want some consistency yeah i don't even
give a [ __ ] believe in it all the whole
time yeah but wear it all the time yeah
yeah man deal where you're gonna be able
to yeah i wanna say what's up to my
friend partying next door bro he's a big
fan of this show dude and of all the
comedians the music part next door yeah
oh [ __ ] and uh i'll be in rockford oh i
got i'll be in rockford illinois you
dropped another name okay server 25 i
did yeah february 25 uh
of 2022 and i'll be at chicago illinois
february 26 of 2022. and you can get
those theovon.com tour and you give out
this year yeah well what's up with the
year
people get confused you say this year
and they think next year or what is that
oh that's this is here
you know he's doing his shows like
electric cars you know it's like
he's coming out in 2025 i'm in chicago
2026 man
that's it love you guys all right guys i
love you
[Music]
brendan guys too yeah you know how we do
it so just tune in for the laughs theo
said that he was on his way but ran out
of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way
now he only finished boys in the
[Music]
eric griffin just walked in and got it
lit you can't forget about brendan he
still need everything dick dick they
still got the bees and the trap trapping
still the king in the sting so quit
asking if you know then you know it's a
cat's thing ball and chain hair swang
like the rat can king and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting